INGRAHAM ANGLE."
>> AMERICA, WANTED OR LEAVE IT,
IF YOU DON'T HAVE RESPECT FOR
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY ANYMORE, IF
YOU DON'T RESPECT MADISONIAN
CHECKS AND BALANCES, IF YOUR A
GUY WHO DOESN'T WIN, IF THAT'S
THE NEW RULES OF ENGAGEMENT FOR
THIS GREAT REPUBLIC, THEN JUST
LEAVE OUR COUNTRY.
GET THE FAX.
WITH IN THE LIGHT, FOLLOW THE
TRUTH, AND LOVE THIS COUNTRY AN
STOP THIS.
>> WHAT DOES THAT REMIND YOU OF?
>> JUST DO IT!
DON'T LET YOUR DREAMS BE DREAMS.
YESTERDAY YOU SAID TOMORROW, SO
JUST DO IT.
MAKE YOUR DREAMS COME TRUE.
>> YOU KNOW, MAYBE HE SHOULD
HAVE HIS OWN MORNING SHOW.
♪
>> SO JOE BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY IS
STARTING OFF WORKS THAN FOX A
FOX AND FRIENDS COOKING SEGMENT.
A LOT OF GREASE FIRES.
FIRST, THE BORDER IS A DISASTER
INFLATION IS ITS HIGHEST SINCE
2008 GREAT THAT'S 13 YEARS FOR
THE TIME IT TOOK BIDEN TO PASS
THE BAR, AND THEN THERE WAS THIS
.
>> MY CLOSE AIDES HAVE BEEN
EXCELLENT.
ONE OF THEM TAUGHT ME THAT AND
QUOTE, THE COAST GUARD IS THAT
HARD NUCLEUS ABOUT WHICH THE
NAVY FORMS IN TIME OF WAR.
>> I CAN ONLY ASSUME YOU ENJOY
EDUCATING YOUR FAMILY ABOUT HOW
THE COAST GUARD IS THE HARD
NUCLEUS AROUND THE NAVY FORMS I
TIMES OF WAR.
YOU ARE A REALLY DULL CLASS.
COME ON, MAN.
>> IS THERE ANYTHING HE HASN'T
PLAGIARIZED?
IT'S TOO BAD HE COULDN'T COPY
AND PASTE THE LAUGHTER TOO.
A KID WHICHEVER PUPPETEER HE IS
CONTROLLED BY.
UNEMPLOYMENT STILL HARLOT HIGHE
THAN CARLY SIMKINS SIMPKINS AT
WORK RIGHT IN BIDEN'S DEFENSE
WERE PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO WORK.
CREATING A SURPLUS OF JOBS.
LIKE ADLER'S PANTS, IT DEFIED
THE LAWS OF.
WHAT WERE THE PRESS COVERING?
MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER SAID THE
FIRST TWO WEEKS OF MAY IT FOUND
ALMOST NO MENTION OF JOE'S
FAILURES FREIGHT A FEW MINUTES
ON INFLATION IF YOU WANT JOBS,
NOTHING ON THE BORDER.
INSTEAD THEY SPENT A COMBINED 3
MINUTES ON LEAVE CHENEY.
NOT THAT YOUR SAVINGS ARE
SHRINKING.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO RANK STORIE
IN ORDER OF IMPORTANCE TO
AVERAGE AMERICANS, THIS STORY
WOULD COME IN SLIGHTLY HIGHER
THAN A GUY FINDING A CHITO THAT
LOOKS LIKE JESUS.
LIZ DIDN'T SEEM TO MIND SHE'S
SOAKED UP ATTENTION AT A KILL
MEET AT A BEACH.
I CALL IT THE STRANGE NEW EARNE
RESPECT DISORDER IT IS WHEN
PEOPLE THAT HATE YOU SUDDENLY
LIKE YOU BECAUSE YOUR USEFUL AN
SINCE THE ATTENTION FEELS GOOD,
YOU GO RIGHT ALONG WITH THE HERD
.
AND HAPPENED WITH IT, IT
HAPPENED WITH ADAM CAN SECURE.
IT HAPPEN WITH VERY MANILOW WHE
HE JOINED THE MANSON FAMILY.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN I JUST NEEDE
A FOURTH EXAMPLE.
IT'S HELPING TO THE BALDHEADED
PINHEADS OF THE LINCOLN PROJECT
BUT THERE TOO DUMB TO REALIZE I
YET.
AS THE MEDIA FLOCKED TO LIZ,
WHAT DID SHE SAY?
>> I WILL DO EVERYTHING I CAN T
ENSURE THAT THE FORMER PRESIDEN
NEVER AGAIN GETS OFFICE FOR A.
>> NOT DOING WHAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WANT, BUT WHAT
MAKES YOU FEEL GOOD BIRD THAT'S
LIKE HOSTING AND NEWS SHOW AND
SHOWING NOTHING, BUT PICTURES O
YOUR DOG.
THAT WILL GET BACK TO HER.
AFTER BEING HATED FOR SO LONG
IT'S NICE TO HAVE THE PRESS
PRETENDING YOU'RE HUMAN.
IS LIKE THAT FAKE FRIEND FROM
SCHOOL THAT GIVES YOU BAD ADVIC
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
AGENDA.
SURE, YOU CAN STUDY FOR THE TES
ON THE BUS IN THE MORNING, NOW
SHOTGUN THIS CAN OF COLT 45.
YOU'LL BE THE MOST FAMOUS PERSO
IN ALGEBRA, OR SURE, I THINK YO
CAN MAKE IT FROM THE ROOF TO TH
SWIMMING POOL.
I SHOULD'VE NEVER SAID THAT TO
SETH.
HE DOESN'T CALL ME ANYMORE.
HE DOESN'T CALL ANYONE ANYMORE.
THAT'S THE MEDIA, THEY WANT YOU
TO DO STUFF THAT'S GOOD FOR THE
AND BAD FOR YOU.
THE LABOR DEPARTMENT REPORTS IS
GROWING AT THE HIGHEST RATE
SINCE APRIL OF 1982.
CBS EVENING NEWS GAVE US ONLY 1
SECONDS WHICH IS THE SAME AMOUN
OF TIME IT TAKES ME TO CLIMB TO
THE TOP OF AS A HUMAN ROCK WHILE
.
THE REASON FOR INFLATION, THE
STIMULUS FOR THAT'S WHAT HAPPEN
WHEN YOU POINT PUMP MORE MONEY
INTO THE SYSTEM.
IT SUPPLY AND DEMAND A LARGER
AMOUNT OF MONEY COMPETES FOR TH
SAME AMOUNT OF STUFF.
IT'S LIKE WHAT HAPPENED TO BRIA
GILMAN.
THE OVEREXPOSED HIM DIMINISHING
A GREAT PRODUCT.
BUT THE MEDIA PUSHED THE
STIMULUS, SO NOW
OH, HEY, JUST HANGING UPSIDE
DOWN BY MY ANKLES.
I DON'T TRUST THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA AT ALL ANYMORE AND I'VE
NEVER BEEN HAPPIER.
I SPENT SO MUCH TIME NOT READIN
THE NEW YORK TIMES IT WAS ME TO
DO ALL THE THINGS I REALLY WANT
TO DO LIKE HANG UPSIDE DOWN BY
MY ANKLES.
WHEN I HANG UPSIDE DOWN BY MY
ANKLES ALL THE BLOOD RUSHES TO
MY HEAD AND IT GIVES ME A
PEACEFUL FEELING.
SOMETIMES I STAY HERE UNTIL THE
WORLD SEEMS RIGHT SIDE UP, AND
THEN WHEN I TURN RIGHT SIDE UP,
THE WORLD SEEMS UPSIDE DOWN.
YOU SHOULD TRY IT.
OR MAY MAYBE NOT.
>> I'M WORRIED ABOUT HIM.
ONCE AGAIN, YOU GET WITH THE
PRESS WANT YOU TO GET, THEIR
INFORMATION OVERLOADS THAT CRAV
CONTROLLED.
IT WASN'T ALWAYS THIS WAY.
CENTURIES AGO THE FIRST REPORTE
ONLY JOTTED DOWN NOTES OF
VILLAGE ACTIVITIES, NO ONE
MINDED BECAUSE IT KEPT THEM FRO
THEIR SHEEP.
THE STORIES WOULD BE SOMETHING
LIKE GOAT SEEN IN FOREST LOOKIN
CONFUSED OR THE COBBLERS SOILED
HIMSELF IN THE PARK OR
JOURNALIST MOUNTS GOAT IN EFFOR
TO SCARE COBBLER, THEN THEY GOT
SELF-IMPORTANT AND BEGAN
INJECTING THEIR OPINIONS INTO
STORIES.
THE EARTH IS FLAT, WOMEN AND
MINORITIES HIT HARDEST.
THEY WENT FROM EXCEEDS IF IT
INTO POWERFUL BECAUSE THEY WROT
THEIR OWN NARRATIVE AND CREATED
THEIR OWN MORE.
THEY WOULD BE THE PROTAGONIST I
ALL OF THEIR STORIES FEARLESS,
DEEPLY MORAL, IN-LINE BECAUSE
LYING EMBELLISHES ALL STORIES.
IT'S OKAY TO BE UNETHICAL IF YO
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
CLASS, TODAY LOCAL STORIES ARE
NOW NATIONAL, OH, SOMEONE LEFT
MEAN MESSAGE ON THAT RESTAURANT
RECEIPTS, LET'S RUIN SOMEONE
REAL QUICK.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS IN
PUSHING CONFLICT FOR ATTENTION
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT TALENTED
ENOUGH TO BE FAMOUS AND ANY
OTHER INDUSTRY.
PRESENT COMPANY EXCLUDED.
TODAY'S PRESS IS LEFT OUIJA
DEMENT THAN A GUY AND AN
JUMPSUIT CLAIMING TO BE YOUR PE
MAC DRIVER.
IT MAY NOT BE THE OLDEST
PROFESSION AND HISTORY, BUT AS
MIGHT AS WELL BE BECAUSE ALL IT
DOES IS SCREW PEOPLE.
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
HE'S OUR NUMBER ONE GUEST WHEN
WE CAN'T GET STEVE DUCEY.
IF YOU THINK HER SMILE IS BRIGHT
, YOU SHOULD SEE HER BRAIN
, ALTHOUGH THAT WOULD
REQUIRE SURGERY.
CARLY SIMPKINS.
HIS PARENTS NAMED HIM CHADWICK
BECAUSE WENTWORTH WAS TAKEN,
EDITOR NOT SPOKEN AND THE
SPECTATOR COLUMN.
LIKE SEWING NEEDLE, SKINNY,
SHARP, AND VERY POPULAR WITH OL
PEOPLE.
>> BRIAN, YOU HAVE NEVER BROKEN
A STORY.
BUT DON'T YOU THINK WHAT YOU'RE
MORE OF A JOURNALIST THAN A
SO-CALLED REPORTERS ARE BECAUSE
AT LEAST YOUR TRUE TO YOURSELF?
>> YES, I'M TRYING TO GET OVER
SHOULD YOU APOLOGIZE TO PETER
DUCEY.
I'VE BEEN HERE SO MUCH, BUT I'V
SAID NOTHING.
WHAT I THINK IS I USED TO ENJOY
SEEING WHAT THE COMPETITION IS
DOING NOW I SEE FICTION AND
NONFICTION AND I DON'T EVEN KNO
WHAT THEY'RE FOCUSING ON.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT JANUARY 6,
AND THEN THERE'S JANUARY 6, AND
THEN WHAT IS DONALD TRUMP DOING?
AND DID I MENTION JANUARY 6?
SO MUCH LEGITIMATELY GOING ON.
HERE IS WHAT I FIND
DISHEARTENING ABOUT THAT.
AS MUCH AS YOU NEED THIS SHOW,
IT DON'T NEED IT TO KNOW THAT
EVERYTHING IS MORE EXPENSIVE.
YOU DON'T NEED TO SHOW TO KNOW
THAT THERE IS GAS WAS NOW $1.98.
SO NOW PEOPLE ARE MAKING THEIR
JUDGMENT THAT WAY FOR THE NEXT
30 SECONDS BOUGHT.
HAVE I GONE OVER MY TIME.
WHEN YOU SAID QUICKLY I THOUGHT
I SHOULD WRAP IT UPRIGHT.
>> I'M NOT EVEN SURE WHAT YOU'R
SAYING.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU COMPLETELY.
WHEN PEOPLE TURN ON THE NEWS,
THEIR NEW THEY'RE BEING LIKED
GREAT ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS
LOOK OUT THE WINDOW.
I HAVE A GOLDEN RULE, IF THE
PRESS SUDDENLY RUTH LIKES YOU,
YOU'RE BETRAYING YOURSELF.
NIGHT TAKE MICHAEL COHEN.
THEY HATED MICHAEL COHEN.
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE'S
LIKE THEIR BEST FRIEND BECAUSE
THEY COULD USE HIM FOR LIKE
SEVEN MINUTES.
>> SPEAKING OF LIKABILITY I
THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING HAPPEN
RIGHT NOW IS THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE VOTED FOR BIDEN BECAUSE
OF HIS PERSONALITY, BECAUSE HE
WAS NICE AND TRUMP WAS MEAN.
WE'RE REALLY STARTING TO SEE
WHAT YOU WHEN YOU HAVE A
PRESIDENT THAT WANTS TO PLEASE
EVERYBODY.
HE THINKS YOU GIVE MONEY TO BOT
IRAN AND PALESTINE.
YOU GREENLIGHT THE RUSSIAN
PIPELINE TO PLEASE GERMANY, YOU
DON'T WEAR A MASK INSIDE WHEN
YOU'RE SITTING NEXT TO THE 96
-YEAR-OLD FORMER PRESIDENT AND
THEN YOU PUT ONE ON FOR THE
CAMERAS OUTSIDE BECAUSE IT'S AL
ABOUT OPTICS AND IT'S ALL ABOUT
APPLAUSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
HE OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T CARE WHAT
PEOPLE THOUGHT ABOUT HIM AND HE
WENT IN THERE LIKE A WRECKING
BALL INSIDE THEY NEED TO PAY
MORE, THE IRANIAN DEAL DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE NEITHER DOES THE
PARIS CLIMATE ACCORD, AND HIS
GOAL WAS REALLY TO MAKE AMERICA
STRONG, JOE BIDEN'S GOAL IS TO
MAINTAIN THE POPULARITY AND
LIKABILITY.
>> CHADWICK, YOU'RE NOT AS
GOOD-LOOKING AS I AM, DOES IT
BOTHER YOU THAT OBJECTS MATTER
MORE THAN CONTENT?
>> WHAT A QUESTION.
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS A GAME NOW.
THIS IS WHO THEY ARE NOW.
AND IT'S SO SHAMELESS, THEY
DON'T EVEN CARE.
THE ONLY WAY IS TO GET AT CLICK.
I'M NOT SURE WHO'S WATCHING.
THE AIRPORT PEOPLE I GUESS.
BUT, IT IS SHAMELESS, AND THEY
HAVE THIS ENERGY LIKE A DRUG
ADDICT ABOUT TO HIT ROCK BOTTOM.
$5, SCRAMBLING ANYTHING, THEY
JUST NEED THE NEXT HIT.
>> THEY NEED TRUMP, THEY NEED
TRUMP.
THEY NEED TRUMP OR CUOMO'S
BECAUSE THE LIBS ARE EATING
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE MASSIVE TRUMP BUFFET
THAT KEPT THEM FAT AND NOW
THEY'RE JUST TEARING EACH OTHER
APART.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT FEELING.
>> OH YEAH.
TEARING THINGS APART FOR IT I
SAW A THEORY RECENTLY AND BE
REAL CLEAR POLITICS SAID THEY H
THINKS THEY EXPECTED THAT HE WA
GOING TO BE PRESIDENT AND JOE
BIDEN GOVERNMENT THAT WHEN
GEORGIA HAPPENED, SO THEY WERE
GOING TO SAY, DO ALL THIS
LIBERAL STUFF, WE WILL DO THIS
TO SEE THE PROGRESSIVES.
THIS AND IT IS GOING TO BE
REPUBLICAN.
AND THEN YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
YOU INVITE SOMEBODY TO GO
SOMEWHERE BECAUSE YOU DON'T
THINK THEY'LL COME.
IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME BECAUSE
IT IS SUCH A NERVOUS AND I THIN
IT'S BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
PREPARED FOR IT.
>> YOU STOP AND YOU THINK ABOUT
THE MEDIA.
IT'S A LAYER OF SUBJECTIVE, IT'
A VARIABLE OF SUBJECTIVE
INTERPRETATION OF LIFE SO THAT
WHEN YOU PUT IT INTO ANY KIND O
ENVIRONMENT, IT CHANGES IT EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT PART OF ITS.
I KEEP THINKING IF THE MEDIA
WASN'T AROUND LAST YEAR, WHAT W
HAVE HAD RIOTS?
WE PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE HAD
RIOTS.
WOULD RACE ME THIS MUCH OF AN
ISSUE IF THERE WASN'T A DEAR?
I'M NOT SAYING WE SHOULD HAVE
IMMEDIATE, BUT I'M NOT NOT
SAYING WE SHOULDN'T HAVE A MEDIA
.
>> I WOULD SAY IT'S NOT HEALTHY
THE REPORTING IS CHANGING.
THERE IS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
THIS CASE, I'M SURE THERE'S
RENEGADES, IN AMERICA WE CUTLET
HAPPENING AND THEN WHEN THE
MEDIA WANTS TO TELL YOU WHAT'S
HAPPENING SO THEY'RE RUNNING
THEIR OWN CHILD.
THE THING IS, THERE IS NO GROUN
TO WHICH.
AM JUST ASTOUNDED, YOU CAN TAKE
IT APART, OBVIOUSLY I LIKE THIS
JAN ALL THE BEST AND THAT'S WHA
I WOULD SAY ON OR OFF CAMERA.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RATINGS, FOR
THE LONGEST TIME AMERICA LIKES
THIS CHANNEL THE BEST.
CNN DIDN'T BREAK A ONE ALL DAY,
WHEN YOU DID REDEYE COME AT YOU
WERE DOUBLING THAT, YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO GET AT
6:00 P.M. IS A COMPOSED TO TO
A.M.
>> MORNING JOE.
WE